avec nous ce soir deborah chers enfants
directrice régionale femmes
entrepreneurs à la td présidente de la
jeune chambre de commerce de montréal
bonsoir bonsoir c'est fillon
comment expliquer selon vous que 25 ans
après la loi sur l'équité salariale au
québec nous en sommes encore là les
femmes qui gagnent de 83 à 93 % du
salaire horaire des hommes
je pense que et je pense pas que ce soit
la pandémie nécessairement même si elle
a exacerbé la situation ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer pour plusieurs plusieurs
éléments notamment la notion de préjugés
je pense qu'il ya des barrières
systémique qui demeure et ça il faut
qu'on soit capable de le dire et des
préjugés qui ont un impact sur la façon
de considérer un peu le travail des
femmes d'une part mais aussi de
considérer des femmes assises et où des
femmes issues de différentes origines
comme un travail qui ne serait pas pour
reprendre un terme qu'on a beaucoup
entendu durant la pandémie qui ne serait
pas essentiel et qui seraient pas à la
hauteur de travail à basculer notre
chance quand il ya cette barrière life
aux enfants science je pense qu'il ya
également un élément de transparence
aussi qui manquent à dans plusieurs
milieux qui fait en sorte qu'on a
peut-être pas toutes les formations
accès à toute l'information en dehors de
milieu du milieu syndical ou de ses
peurs ou effectivement cette information
est un état c'est à diffuser et passer
plus blick même mais n'en demeure pas
moins que dans d'autres milieux dans les
affaires ce n'est pas une information à
laquelle ont accès facilement ce qui
fait en sorte que les femmes ne savent
pas comment se comparent et encore moins
négocier
est-ce que l'écart est encore plus grand
avec les hommes chez les femmes
autochtones les femmes immigrantes les
femmes racisées les femmes noires
définitivement je n'ai malheureusement
pas les chiffres plus à jour mais je
sais que en 2016 insulta statistiques ça
et justement des données sur
cet écart là qui persistent entre les
femmes noires à s'user les fabre a cité
les femmes autochtones et on peut voir
clairement à quel point il ya les corps
était quand même assez élevé et on peut
voir et quand je parlais de préjugés de
barrières systémique on voit
définitivement que les pâtes et les
conséquences que cela peut avoir une
once entendants dans l'ascension
professionnelle mais dans les conditions
de travail le salaire alors comment on
change comment on franchit les obstacles
qui sont ce que racontent les femmes en
affaires des femmes noires notamment 9h
pense que le fait d'en parler déjà ça
c'est une première
une première démarche de pouvoir
constater le problème et au delà du
constat faut aller dans les actions
comme vous le dites monsieur fillion et
et parmi les actions nous par exemple
pas la td on a choisi d'avoir des
approche personnalisée comme le le
segment et dont je suis responsable par
l'entrepreneur également les collègues à
des termes qui gère des segments destiné
aux personnes d'autochtones aux
personnes noires également on veut dire
quoi concrètement
donnez nous du contraire par rapport à
ça tout à fait en fait c'est une
approche personnalisée non seulement à
long terme pour former nos collègues
avec de la formation pour comprendre et
bien conscient et culturels la dynamique
aussi qui peut exister en dehors de
certaines communautés je le dis comme ça
qu'il s'agisse de la communauté jpy
ti-cul plus qu'il s'agisse de des
communautés autochtones
donc pour informer et éduquer mais nos
collègues en interne sur cette disparité
ces inégalités également sur la
dimension intrinsèque à ces communautés
donc le travail en effet mais aussi à
l'expérience nous concrètement on va
travailler avec les organismes qui
soutiennent ces communautés là donc on
va financer des programmes qui sont
destinés à ces à ces communautés pour
nous assurer de mieux les accompagner
mais si nous arrivons à la panoplie de
services et de produits
mes concerts puis sur les organismes du
milieu pour les européennes
vous êtes aussi pdg en ce moment de la
jeune chambre de commerce de montréal
on a vu dans les statistiques beaucoup
de femmes qui sont sortis de la
population active de la force de travail
comme
comme on l'appelle comment stimuler pour
ces femmes-là particulièrement
l'entrepreneuriat des femmes dans ces
conditions je pense que de plusieurs
façons mais un ou deux éléments que je
pourrai partager avec vous surtout comme
préoccupation pour cette relève
d'affaires que je représente à titre de
président et parle donc plus important
aussi de changer les moules et modèles
et je pense qu'aux sorties ont même si
on est encore là dedans de cette crise
est important de mettre de l'avant
différents visages différents modèles de
l'entrepreneuriat pour inspirer cette
roulette d'affaires pour montrer que
c'était accessible que c'est possible
d'autres façons aussi pourrait être mais
comme l'annoncé du de la mini char est
aujourd'hui avec des programmes pour
aller dans le concret et des pour le
plan d'affaires et d un véritablement à
faire en sorte que les prochaines
entreprises auxquelles cette préférence
est une une dimension j'ai envie de dire
sanitaire une dimanche une réflexion à
cuba au delà de la pandémie et puis sept
ans mesure hausse avec et dont je pense
que ça prend des moyens concrets
soutenu par le gouvernement bien
évidemment vous faire en sorte qu'on
donne à cette folle et veulent les
outils et faut pas oublier non plus que
cette relève est quand même assez
inspiré par l'aspect durable a généré un
impact dont il faut donner les moyens
fait en sorte que cette rue il en soit
inclusive mais aussi fait du mal pour
cette relève très bien d'abord à leurs
enfants merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
merci devant l'habitation bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit